Let's look at how
sports scheduling can
be done with optimization by
starting with a small example.
Suppose we're trying to schedule
a tournament between four
teams-- Atlanta, Boston,
Chicago, and Detroit.
We'll call these
teams A, B, C, and D.
These teams are divided
into two divisions.
Atlanta and Boston
are in one division,
and Chicago and Detroit
are in the second division.
Each team plays one game a
week for a total of four weeks.
During the four weeks, each
team plays the other team
in the same division
twice, and each team
plays the teams in the
other divisions once.
The team with the most
wins from each division
will play in the
championship game.
For this reason, teams prefer
to play divisional games later.
If team A plays team C and
D in the first two weeks
and wins both games while
team B also plays team C and D
and loses both games,
A knows that they only
need to win one of
the games against B
to beat B in terms of wins
and to go to the championship.
We can schedule this tournament
by using an optimization model.
Our objective is to maximize
team preferences, which
are that teams would like to
play divisional games later.
Our decisions are
which teams should
play each other each week.
And we have three
types of constraints.
Each team needs to play the
other team in their division
twice, each team needs to play
the teams in the other division
once, and each team should play
exactly one team each week.
Let's start by discussing
our decision variables.
We need to decide which teams
will play each other each week.
To do this, let's define
decision variables
which we'll call x_ijk.
If team i plays
team j in week k,
then x_ijk will be equal to 1.
Otherwise, x_ijk equals 0.
As an example, suppose team
A plays team C in week 2.
Then x_AC2 would equal 1.
Since A only plays C
once, we should have then
that x_AC1, or A playing C in
week 1, should be equal to 0.
Similarly, x_AC3 should equal
0, and x_AC4 should equal 0.
This is called a binary
decision variable
since it's a decision
variable that
can only take two
values, 0 and 1.
This is a new type
of decision variable,
and it's what makes
integer optimization
different from
linear optimization.
The decision variables
in integer optimization
can only take integer values.
This includes binary
decision variables,
like the ones we have here,
that can only be either 0 or 1.
These variables
can model decisions
like where to build
a new warehouse,
whether or not to
invest in a stock,
or assigning nurses to shifts.
Integer optimization
problems can also
have integer decision variables
that take values 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
etc.
These variables
can model decisions
like the number of new
machines to purchase,
the number of workers
to assign for a shift,
and the number of items
to stock in a store.
Other than the new types of
variables, integer optimization
is exactly like
linear optimization.
But we'll see this week how
integer optimization variables,
and especially binary variables,
can increase our modeling
capabilities.
Now let's go back
to our formulation.
As we said before,
our decisions are
which teams should play
each other each week.
We'll model this with the
binary decision variables
we just discussed--
x_ijk which equal 1
if team i plays
team j in week k.
Now let's use these
decision variables
to form our constraints.
The first constraint
is that each team
should play the other team
in their division twice.
So teams A and B should
play each other twice
in the four weeks.
This can be modeled with the
constraint x_AB1 + x_AB2 +
x_AB3 + x_AB4 = 2.
This will force two of
these decision variables
to be equal to 1, and the
other two decision variables
to be equal to 0.
The ones that are equal to 1
will correspond to the weeks
that A and B will
play each other.
We'll have a similar
constraint for teams C and D.
Our next constraint
is that each team
should play the teams in
the other division once.
So teams A and C should
play each other once
in the four weeks.
This can be modeled with a
constraint x_AC1 + x_AC2 +
x_AC3 + x_AC4 = 1.
This is very similar to
the previous constraint,
except this time only one
of the decision variables
will have value 1.
We'll have similar
constraints for teams A and D,
teams B and C, and teams B and
D. Our last type of constraint
is that each team
should play exactly one
other team each week.
This means that A should
play B, C or D in week 1.
This can be modeled
with a constraint x_AB1
+ x_AC1 + x_AD1 = 1.
Exactly one of these decision
variables will be equal to 1,
meaning that A will play
that team in week 1.
We'll have a similar constraint
for every team and week pair.
Now, let's model our objective.
Let's assume that teams
have a preference of 1
for playing divisional games
in week 1, a preference of 2
in week 2, a preference of 4
for playing divisional games in
week 3, and a preference of 8
for playing divisional
games in week 4.
So the preference doubles
with each later week.
Then we can model our objective
as x_AB1 + 2*x_AB2 + 4*x_AB3 +
8*x_AB4 + x_CD1 + 2*x_CD2
+ 4*x_CD3 + 8*x_CD4.
Then if team AB plays in week
3, we'll add 4 to our objective.
If they play in
week 1, then we'll
only add 1 to our objective.
If they don't play in a
week, that term will be 0
and will not contribute
to the objective.
Now that we've set
up our problem,
we're ready to solve it.
In the next video, we'll
set up and solve our problem
in LibreOffice.